[Musica]
Vi è mai capitato di avere una giornata
lunga di quelle troppo lunghe stressante
al lavoro complicata con i figli mille
impegni alla metà dei quali Siete
arrivati in ritardo
e domani
ancora peggio cento pensieri per la
testa e neanche questa volta vi siete
presi cura di voi stessi ma finalmente
siete a casa È stata per andare a
dormire state per chiudere gli occhi e
proprio in quel momento vi state per
abbandonare i vostri pensieri Ecco il
vostro peggior nemico quello che vi
tiene svegli tutta la notte e fa
schizzare il cortisolo a mille l'ormone
dello stress
Ecco sicuramente avreste preferito
dormire in una camera silenziosa ma
purtroppo sono anni che dormite in un
cantiere un po' come quello della
Salerno Reggio Calabria infinito
ecco chi di voi vive una situazione
simile a questa sua alzate le mani su
Secondo me Ecco vedo che siete in buona
compagnia dai
sapevate che il 50% degli uomini adulti
è il 25 per cento delle donne adulte
russa
Mica poco
il russamente la terza causa di divorzio
negli Stati Uniti d'America
pare che dormendo in camere separate le
coppie vado incontro a un deterioramento
del loro rapporto e lo hanno dimostrato
Alcuni studi scientifici di chiederete
Ma tanto a me importa poco io dormo solo
oppure il mio partner ha un sonno
particolarmente pesante non lo sente il
mio arrossamento e no Miei cari
irussamento non rappresenta solo un
insidia esclusivamente relazionale è
molto di più è fortunatamente la
tecnologia ci viene incontro con delle
App che possono registrare il nostro
sogno il nostro russamento e quindi
darci una risposta anche senza partner
ma adesso per spiegarvi Perché dovreste
interessarvi al vostro russamento
facciamo insieme un esperimento
tratteniamo il respiro per 20 secondi
senza prendere fiato però concentratevi
e lo dobbiamo fare tutti qui eh mi
raccomando Al mio tre uno due tre
manca l'aria il cuore inizia a battere
un po' all'impazzata non è una
sensazione piacevole ammettiamolo
questo che avete appena provato è quello
che vive una persona affetta da apnee
notturne
nella persona con apneese vere questo
fenomeno si verifica almeno ogni due
minuti dura almeno 10 secondi e
determina un calo dell'ossigenazione
corporea
in un caso estremo si arriva a passare
la metà del proprio sonno senza aria
Quindi se ipotizziamo la persona che
dorme mediamente 6 ore questo significa
tre ore senza aria senza ossigeno con
conseguenze non indifferenti
Allora in una persona sana l'aria passa
dal naso e attraverso la trachea finisce
nei polmoni senza incontrare resistenze
ma in Chi russa qualcosa si inceppa a
livello della gola a livello del palato
per l'esattezza che perde tono muscolare
inizia a vibrare vigorosamente generando
questo fastidioso rumore Esatto Non è un
fenomeno nasale come molti di voi
potevano pensare
ma in una quota non poco significativa
di pazienti questo meccanismo si altera
ancora di più avviene un collasso delle
vie aeree proprio qui tra il palato la
lingua e la laringe e questo collasso
questo ostruzione porta una pausa
respiratoria un apnea per l'appunto
Dunque abbiamo detto che in qualche modo
Questo è un fenomeno che interessa un
po' Tutti chi di noi non conosce un
russatore
tutti per la statistica 40 di voi
potrebbero essere russatori e venti di
voi malati di apnea notturna senza
esserne consapevoli
ma vi domanderete Ma in che modo questo
russamento questa apnea spegnerebbero il
fuoco della passione
state pensando a quella passione lì ma
il mio ragionamento è molto più ampio e
abbraccia più aspetti della nostra vita
Infatti un virus in Chi va in apnea ad
esempio il sonno diventa poco riposante
ci potremmo sentire molto stanchi al
mattino nervosi in casi estremi si
potrebbero verificare anche degli
addormentamenti improvvisi con delle
conseguenze che come potete immaginare a
volte possono essere irreparabili
Chi russa E chi va in apnea può essere
particolarmente stressato potrebbe
presentare problemi della sfera sessuale
anche deficit della del campo
intellettuale quindi intellettivi
Ma chi va in apnea e chi va in apnea in
maniera Severa potrebbe aumentare il
proprio rischio di sviluppare malattie
dell'apparato cardiovascolare
la prima causa di morte al mondo
una persona con apnea hai un rischio
doppio di sviluppare ictus infarto e
addirittura triplo di morire di cause
cardiache rispetto a una persona sana
sono numeri terrificanti
basta terrorismo giuro adesso cerchiamo
di affrontare questa situazione in
maniera pratica troviamo una soluzione
insieme ma prima cerchiamo di capire una
cosa un terzo della nostra vita circa la
passiamo dormendo
significa che una persona di 50 anni ha
dormito circa 16 anni della propria vita
Un tempo non da poco
il sonno viene visto da ognuno di noi
come qualcosa di passivo Sicuramente
poco entusiasmante non tanto
entusiasmante quanto le nostre attività
la svegli ma senza un sonno di qualità
non potremmo recuperare quelle energie
psicofisiche utili a svolgere le nostre
attività quotidiane e se questo sonno
diventa patologico come abbiamo visto
prima Apriti cielo rischiamo anche di
non svolgerle queste attività
La verità è che non stiamo qui a
prenderci in giro non prestiamo la
stessa attenzione al nostro sonno
rispetto alle nostre attività svegli
piuttosto dovremmo imparare ad
ascoltarci di più soffriamo di risvegli
notturni Siamo sonnolenti al mattino
abbiamo mal di testa al mattino Beh in
questo caso potresti aver bisogno di
vedere un esperto in disturbi
respiratori del sonno può essere un
otorinolaringoiatra un neurologo uno
pneumologo che è lo specialista in
malattia è l'apparato respiratorio
Insomma qualcuno che abbia una
competenza specifica è che porti il
paziente a una diagnosi possibilmente
con una registrazione dei parametri
cardio respiratori del sonno che si
chiama polysonnografia uno strumento
sofisticato che quantifica russamente da
apnea
ma adesso arriva il bello parliamo di
come smettere di russare e di come
riprendere a respirare la notte in
maniera adeguata
la prima cosa da fare è lavorare sul
nostro stile di vita
uno stile di vita sano attività fisica
una dieta equilibrata in alcuni casi
anche dimagrante se abbiamo mangiato
qualche Cappelletto di troppo
e poi un ritmo sonno veglia adeguato
andare a letto più o meno sempre la
stessa ora a svegliarsi in maniera
regolare
e tra le soluzioni terapeutiche che
fortunatamente sono tante una di quelle
più utilizzate la terapia ventilatoria
un ventilatore con una maschera che si
chiama cpap che si indossa la notte e
consente un'adeguato ossigenazione del
nostro organismo una terapia molto
efficace ma purtroppo abbandonato nel
40% dei casi dai pazienti perché perché
la maschera può essere un po' opprimente
perché la macchina fa un po' di rumore
perché il nostro partner non ha voglia
di dormire con l'uomo mascherato magari
un'altra soluzione può essere un
apparecchio ortodontico che assomiglia
in qualche modo al paradenti dei pugili
per intenderci si indossa si calza la
notte avanza la mandibola stabilizza le
vie aeree il paziente non russa e non va
in apnea
esiste poi un tipo specifico di persone
che russe ben appreso solo in posizione
supina quindi a pancia in su in questo
caso potremmo anche consigliare un
dissuasore di posizione un collare che
vibra quando siamo a pancia in su ci
porta a spostarci sul fianco e
sostituisce in qualche modo la classica
gomitata che ci viene rifilata durante
il sonno
Scherzi a parte
l'ultima soluzione è quella chirurgica
che consente di correggere Quei difetti
del naso della gola o della mascella che
possono favorire o determinare il
russamente le apnee
Insomma vi ho parlato un po' di quello
che è un problema molto complesso di
quali sono i rischi il modo di
diagnosticarlo e come affrontarlo dal
punto di vista terapeutico oggi questa
gestione di tipo individualizzato
sartoriale parliamo col paziente
presentiamo le soluzioni possibili
escludiamo quelle controindicate
valutiamo però e contro di ciascuna e
arriviamo a una soluzione condivisa
e adesso vi ricordate di quella giornata
che era lunga all'inizio eh Quella è
sempre lunga io non posso risolvervi
tutti i problemi alla vostra vita lo
stress c'è e non possiamo
privarcene ma
ma adesso le nostre notti sono
migliorate
abbiamo fatto il primo passo
le nostre notti sono migliorate e quindi
anche i nostri giorni lo sono
e l'ormone dello stress il cortisolo
vedi quello adesso nemmeno l'ombra
adesso mi raccomando chiudiamo tutti gli
occhi
stiamo andando a dormire
ci abbandoniamo i nostri pensieri e
Buonanotte a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]